hi i'm david kwong i'm a new york times
crossword puzzle constructor a
cruciverbalist
and i'm going to show you how to make a
crossword puzzle
what is a puzzle well puzzles are all
around us there are problems everywhere
but a good puzzle makes the solver feel
smart i've loved puzzles since i was a
kid and i'm also a magician so i think
that all magic tricks are puzzles that's
why i have those two worlds colliding
and as an enigmatist somebody who
performs puzzles i'm presenting them to
you i'm challenging your brain getting
you to think outside the box
and hopefully have that aha moment when
you can feel smart
the aha moment is when you crack the
puzzle
you're solving a puzzle and everything
just clicks into place
across your puzzle is a type of word
puzzle where there's always an across
and down every letter is checked meaning
if you don't know one way you could
probably figure it out the other way it
was invented in 1913 it's over 100 years
old by arthur wynn it first appeared in
the new york world in college i started
constructing crossword puzzles a friend
showed me how to do it i started mailing
them into the new york times they were
getting rejected left and right but
finally i broke through
and uh will shorts the editor the guru
of puzzles is a good friend and mentor
now and i've been
writing for the times and other major
newspapers ever since this is the size
of the daily puzzle in the new york
times crossword 15 by 15. sunday is 21
by 21
monday is the easiest day of the week
and saturday is the hardest the first
thing you need to do when writing a
puzzle is come up with your theme
a bit of word play that will run
throughout the puzzle
and because i'm a magician i'm going to
make the theme of my crossword playing
cards
so my goal is to hide 10 jack queen king
and ace inside
other words
after you've come up with your theme
you'll have to write down the long
answers and these are parallel and
length so if you have a 10 letter answer
you'll need another 10 letter answer if
you only have one 13 letter answer
that's fine it can go right in the
middle of the grid and it's like this in
every puzzle open up the newspaper and
you'll see rotational symmetry
so in the case of this puzzle i have
marquee name i'm going to put that right
in the middle of the 15 wide grid that's
11 letters
you can see that
queen is contained there one two three
four five six seven in the middle of the
grid
marquee name
and because i'm such a huge zac efron
fan
let's put in
zac
efron
which gives us our ace
and
queen
and now to put in the black squares we
call this particular shape a utah
and i'll place another one on this side
you don't want to put too many black
squares because the words get smaller
the puzzle's too easy which is why on a
friday and a saturday there are fewer
black squares and there's lots of white
space lots of long words which makes the
puzzle challenging sac efron will have a
triple
stack here like this
and i will do one more one two three
four five six seven eight
up here
jack is almost impossible to hide
between two words so i'm just going to
make sure it doesn't start or end the
phrase
life jacket
gets us our jack
and because that's 10 liters long
i've decided to do
skin grafts we'll do the plural put in a
black square here
and another one
down here so we're good with jack
and
king
we have a lot of options for t and 10
can be buried in a number of words
because zac efron is eight letters gonna
find a suitable one for this corner
split
and
so here's our hidden
and let's talk about symmetry
it's not horizontal or vertical symmetry
it's rotational symmetry so if we flip
the board upside down 180 degrees the
black squares will be in the same places
so
if i take
a black square and place it here
i keep the symmetry by placing one there
as well i'll break up the middle
and a nice pattern
keeping the symmetry there are other
rules when it comes to the black squares
you don't want clumps you don't want it
to look
ugly so you have nice diagonal lines
often
now you also want to place the black
squares to break up difficult letter
combinations this f
z area is problematic so i'm going to
place one above
the z
because it's easier to start a word with
a z than to end it because we have one
here let's do one
up here as well
which leaves us with this area f blank
blank e blank blank f
which should probably be
everyone's favorite john wu film
face
off
so we have some difficult letter
combinations i'm going to have to
address this q
and then also over here if i make this
word start with an m and end with an f
i'm going to have to look up some letter
patterns that are m blank blank blank f
there are great databases that search
entire dictionaries and if you put in
m
question mark question mark question
mark question mark f you're basically
telling the engine to look for those
parameters
so
i'll go to every puzzler's favorite
website onelook.com
and put in
m these are any letter those question
marks and it's already showing me
results
make of is great i see
massive there
most def is a great one
so m and ending in f breaking up this
area
put in most
def i'll keep the symmetry
and put it up top
as well
a couple here and ending in a that'll
probably be iguana or ithaca
and then this u blink blank a blank word
i would love to put ureas in there but
will short says that does not pass the
sunday morning breakfast test so
yuvia's
it is part of your eye
once you've placed your long theme
answers in the grid you're going to fill
around it phil or all the other little
letters that make up the puzzle so
you'll put in your black squares you're
going to break up difficult areas and
you'll try to fill section by section
it's a combination of looking things up
and recognizing patterns
okay
another rule is that there aren't any
two letter answers everything has to be
at least three letters long and then
every letter has to be checked that's to
be both across and down so if there's a
piece of obscure trivia then you should
be able to answer it by accessing it
from the other direction saws that's not
good i'm going to have to change this to
make of
to interpret something
my apologies to most def sometimes you
have to change the grid
and that's eastside morales of nypd blue
he's always in the puzzle because of his
vowels
along with yoko ono and brian eno
usually your theme answers are the long
ones that run across the grid but
sometimes you can sneak them in the
corners and this is really nice royal
flush happens to be five and five so i'm
gonna put those in the corners may not
a devotee of dionysus which i had to
look up
and uh we'll finish this out here with
f major and tata for now
pretty cool
[Music]
so now that you've set the grid it's
time to write the clues there are easier
clues on a monday
harder clues later in the week that's up
to the editor's discretion but let's
let's write some clues for this puzzle
all right well let's start with one of
the themers life jacket
could be clued as see
safety
need
texan an easy monday clue might be
el
paso resident
if it were a uh saturday clue it might
be
afc south member something like that you
always see you in the puzzle we'll put
in the clue here you mate for ram
and then let's put a tricky one in for
tony
and do
be
arthur
one one
for
mame i think
once you've written your clues you have
to do a final check to make sure that
none of the words and the clues appear
in the grid already
so
i couldn't have for example for texan
the clue could not be one who lives in
el paso because i have ones
already as an answer in the grid so el
paso resident
works there
and voila now you know how to make a new
york times crossword puzzle
and i couldn't help myself
i hid another puzzle in this video the
answer
is a word that has to do with this theme
so don't go any further if you want to
solve it
go back and take a look
i'll wait
[Music]
so how'd you do did you notice the
different letters on my lapel pin
o-i-d-m-d-n-a
and you may have noticed
that my shirt was changing color
and that will help you put those letters
in order
take those colors and their
corresponding letters and put them in
roygbiv order
and you get d-i-a-m-o-n-d
diamond which nicely completes our royal
flush theme and just for fun i hid three
other words in the video as well
that complete the set
but i'm not going to tell you where
those are
so take a look
and happy solving
[Music]
you